we are in December now which means it's
almost 2018 which means you need a
calendar for your wall for 2018 and 2018
david pakman show calendars are here are
our goal this year is to send out 250 or
more David Pakman show
calendars in the first few days we got
30 or more orders for them so far so we
are in really good shape I do want to
tell you a little more about the
calendar the calendars are it's 100
percent david pakman show audience
created art so three of our viewers and
listeners created the David Pakman show
calendar art it's a combination of comic
strips cartoon type work and you see
that there's one storyline where I grow
a huge beard and it's a really really
funny thing that we're showing our TV
audience right now but we're not going
to show you every comic strip because
that would be what would the point be of
doing that they we've got to leave
something to the imagination and then
also some other great artwork from our
audience and you can get the calendar
for free if you want it with a new
yearly membership you can find out about
that at david pakman.com slash calendar
18 so with a new yearly membership we
will ship you a calendar autographed at
no cost whatsoever you can also go to
david pakman.com slash calendar 18 and
click through to get just the calendar
and you have the option of getting it
autographed or not and either way these
make really really great gifts it's a
great conversation starter to put
particularly if you work in a
conservative office I think that this is
a great thing to put on the wall I know
Pat you have how many dozens of these
things are you putting up all in your
car at this point you're just after get
new memberships now I already have like
6070 thousand yeah I know it's a whole
complex thing you should see what's
going on with Pat's a credit card
churning game ok he's flying around the
world for free because of the number of
calendars and memberships he's buying
also Pat I do want to mention if you'll
allow me that members and patrons get a
discount off of the calendar so if you
want to get the calendar discount you
can just become a patron for a dollar a
month right you put in $1 a month on
patreon and then you'll find out
the huge calendar discount code so
listen the bottom line my message is
there is no shortage of different ways
that you can get this calendar either
for free discounted autograph not
autographed and it's a really good way
to support our show for the end of the
year and it's actually something you'll
use all year long or that someone you
gift it to will use instead of one of
those weird
nobody needs a fifth pizza cutter it's
probably more useful than a david pakman
show colander a cut yeah we've actually
the calendars are only useful if you're
part of the Church of the Flying
Spaghetti Monster yeah and you want to
have your license picture taken with it
on but otherwise don't go with the
colander go with the calendar the david
pakman show calendar david pakman.com
slash calendar 18 these things are
flying out of here just off camera
it's just stacked to the wall to the
ceiling of calendars pack can barely get
in the office because of how many
calendars we have in here